quantizing so I gave a talk in the
quantum boot camp a couple weeks ago um
that's kind of about similar things I
decided that since I have the
opportunity another opportunity to talk
I'll talk about something get a little
bit more technical so apologies for that
okay so first let's talk about some
context oh and by the way I'm gonna be
talking about this work which is joint
with night way entourage chung-yong on
chin and chin Hall right so there's been
a recent line of work that's basically
trying to solve sort of a problem with
quantum machine learning research which
is that a lot of quantum machine
learning algorithms they're sort of like
quantum linear algebra and these
algorithms run in time poly logarithmic
in dimension right and in order to do
this they make strong input assumptions
like let's say I have my I have I can
make input states corresponding to
classical beta right so I can have like
I can like wait my quantum states
corresponding to the weight of input
data and so this quantum machine
learning algorithm gets time sort of
like exponentially faster than any sort
of machine learning algorithm and the
question is whether this is something
that can manifest in practice so is this
like an exponential speed-up that you
could use eventually or whether under
similar input assumptions classically
you could also find a corresponding
classical algorithm that basically does
the same task maybe with some polynomial
slowdown so basically the question is
whether this exponential speed-up this a
sensible exponential speed-up is
manifesting because of the input
assumptions or because of the quantum
and there's been a recent set of work
that sort of suggests that there is no
exponential
speed up if you sort of assume that
you're giving your empathy to
classically so you can so you can
compare classical and quantum and also
you these and you can you can remove
this exponential speed-up or exponential
separation if your quantum algorithm
needs to operate on low rank or close to
low rank data and the way this is argued
is by giving log dimension time
classical randomized linear algebra
algorithms in some sort in a in a input
model that's supposed to be analogous to
the quantum input model used for quantum
machine learning so namely I'm talking
about this this cube Ram here and so so
this is sort of like the line of work
that we're going to be building off of
this work is also inspired by this
singular value transformation framework
for quantum linear algebra there's been
a recent set of works that has
generalized a lot of the ideas behind a
lot of quantum algorithms like this
quantum walk stuff in sparse matrix
inversion and quanta machine learning
and it's able to do this generalize this
into like so a broad quantum linear
algebra framework the general idea is
that given a specific assumption on your
input matrix you can apply a singular
value transformation of that matrix to a
quantum state so this is this works for
this this block encoding condition don't
worry about it if you haven't seen it
before it basically this is just gonna
serve as like inspiration but what we're
gonna do moving forward and we're going
to be considering Q RAM based algorithms
and I'll explain more later so given
that this quantum this singular value
transformation unified quantum
algorithms the question is whether we
can do the same thing to unify these
quantum inspired algorithms because
they're all using different ideas or I
guess uh they're they're all like
proving everything from scratch and so
our main result is that we can give a Cu
our decomposition which is as probably
mentioned before I'll explain again in a
little bit we can give a Cu our
decomposition for an even singular
Valley transformation of an input matrix
in this sample and query access model
that I mentioned before and further all
quantum inspired algorithms sort of up
to now can be recovered as basically
like corollaries simple simple
corollaries of this main theorem and
essentially what you can think about
this is is like a classical version of Q
am based singular value transformation
but there's some like slight there's
some slight difference in the function
specific parameters there okay so I'm
going to talk about some of the
groundwork first so I'm gonna be using
the singular value decomposition a lot
this is just an expression of a as you
know to unit Ares and a diagonal matrix
the same with these are like the
singular vectors and singular values
respectively in this context the
Frobenius norm is basically the l2 norm
of the singular values and I'm going to
be using the singular value
transformation notion which is that
given this function f that operates on
scalars I'm going to use F of a to refer
to applying it to I'm going to say F of
a is a except I've applied after all the
singular values
and this is like a this is like the
essential notion that basically a lot of
ponts machine learning algorithms can
just be written as some type of like
singular value transformation on your
input right so here's kind of what this
cue Ram based singular value
transformation that I mentioned looks
like the idea is that we have a bunch of
copies of some input state and you're
able to get as output Apollo no - a
singular value transformation of a
applied to V so here I'm using this cat
V to refer to just just like weighted
superposition position and here I'm
assuming that A's and q Ram and so and
that P is like a degree D polynomial so
there's the assumption that you need to
be working with polynomials here and the
thing to notice here is as I mentioned
before this runs in time logarithmic in
dimension where I guess they might be
like poly logarithmic depending on how
you count and so the question is whether
this is actually manifesting in like
some sort of exponential speed-up so you
should think about this by the way this
for be nice norm over spectrum will come
up a good amount you can think about
this this is called this like stable
rank in the classical literature you can
think about it as an analogue a smooth
analogue for rank it's bounded by the
square roots of the rank of a so it's
kind of kind of make sense so the thing
to notice about this algorithm is that
this like we do we do run very quickly
but but we need some way to prepare
these quantum states corresponding to V
and to get something useful from the
output and further like we I guess we
also need to like put a and Q Ram as
well
and all of these are not sublinear time
in general
and since having these input and output
be quantum states and assuming that your
a is some sort of nice blocking coding
these are all strong assumptions our
classical algorithm that serves as an
analog will need similarly strong
assumptions and what we'll use is
sampling query access is an analog so so
for quantum machine learning that looks
like in like in putting quantum state to
output in quantum state we'll be
studying the classical analog which is
sample of prairie access to input to
sample and query access to output so I'm
going to define this notion and it turns
out that this it turns out that
algorithms be quantized what I call the
quantized algorithms that it's
algorithms that are in this model serve
as good analogs to these quantum machine
learning algorithms that is under pretty
pretty reasonable assumptions if you
have a fast algorithm in in the sample
and query access model then we don't
know how to give an exponential like
like there are no exponential except
like then then basically we can conclude
that this quantum machine learning
algorithm does not give an exponential
separation basically this is a weak
enough assumption if we assume that the
data is giving classically so I'm going
to go ahead and define this sampling for
your access now okay so we have sample
and query access to a particular vector
if we can quickly compute entries of
that vector we can measure X in the
computational basis that is I just want
to sample a particular index I with
probability proportional to X I squared
this is also called length squared
sampling and I also want to efficiently
determine its norm
so you can see that this is actually a
pretty weak assumption if you assume
that your input data is giving
classically then it makes sense that if
your quantum algorithm gets to have
quantum states you get to at least have
measurements of them but actually you
know in most cases where quantum machine
learning operates you can get these
measurements classically without going
to a quantum state okay and
correspondingly for matrix we have
sampling Cree access to that matrix if
we have sampling corey access to all of
its rows and also a tilde which is the
vector of row norms so the AI entry is
the norm of the I throw and just to note
here if we have an Okie time algorithm
in this model then actually getting
sampling for e axis is just building a
data structure and this takes time
basically like linear in the number of
nonzero entries nnz of your input and so
you can basically translate an algorithm
in this notion to a standard algorithm
and a standard classical algorithm the
reason I mentioned this is because the
this is this this sort of bound without
the poly log is basically the ideal the
sort of the the runtime that a lot of
classical randomized linear algebra
algorithms shoot for so we can think
about this as a sort of like a
restricted model or I guess a a version
of classical algorithm where we have a
more restricted notion of what we can do
with this and Enzi time anyways so now
that I defined I've defined the sampling
query access you might start to see some
connections to Robbie's talk where
there's this observation that sampling
query access speeds up machine learning
and randomized linear algebra a lot so I
think this may be these two were
mentioned explicitly in the previous
talk and basically
how we do this is that how we how this
conceit of machine learning is by
considering the following sketching
sketch of the ability to sketch down
input matrices so so if we have a matrix
a will say that we can give an important
sampling of Sketchup a if I says rows
are chosen uniformly at random and they
look like this so they're basically we
have a 1 and want to they have their
basically what what these s eyes are
there they are selecting rows of a so
how you can form s is that you sample
from a tilled and then you take the I
that you get from sampling and then you
rescale that particular row so what I'm
saying here is that sa is the thing that
we want right and then when you take si
you get that B si is a normalized subset
of rows of a and yes this is exactly
what probably talked about with columns
I'm using rows because a slightly
different convention yeah so this is
exactly what he discussed before and the
thing to notice is that because we had
sampling chorong access to a so that
means we could sample quickly this means
that we can find this si really fast so
in time independent of dimension just Oh
a best time and further you can think
about this to verify it's a little
annoying but but given sample query
access to a you can actually simulate
sampling quarry access to si and I say
dagger
and this is just you have to just think
about it a little bit but the nice thing
about this important sampling sketch is
that you basically inherit sample and
quarry access from a right when I say
find I basically mean I basically mean
when I say this stamp sq of si I mean I
take OFS time and then I have a sampling
quarry access to these two si okay and
again something that Robbie said is that
this important sampling can approximate
matrix products so if you have sampling
query access a and B then we can
approximate a a conjugate transpose B by
SA and SB where these are sketch down
versions of a and B and we get basically
additive error here and and we get
additive error by taking samples a
number of samples independent of
dimension so and here again as before
our sample RS s/insp are normalized sub
matrices of a and B and so you have
sampling query access to all of your
approximations as well and so if you
found all of the access model stuff
confusing it's fine because this is
actually the only thing that we use so
if you believe that performing these
sketching sketches of approximating
matrix products if you believe that you
can do that fast then everything else
just follows from this primitive
effectively
effectively the sort of sampling query
access model the only thing that we
don't yeah I guess the only thing that
we use about it is that you can
approximate these matrix products
quickly so this is just what we're going
to use moving forwards so just
approximating a dagger B and and and
look notice that what we're doing here
is that we're reducing the dimension
down in this matrix product down to s
and since we get sampling quarry axis
and the approximation we can use this
repeatedly to reduce dimensions in
matrix products so if you do this thing
of repeatedly reducing matrix products
eventually you're going to be left with
something called an R u R decomposition
so this is just a variance of the CER
decomposition where here I'm looking at
a particular matrix a and then instead
of having a Cu are where the C's the
column column is the subset of columns
of a and the R is the subset of rows of
a instead I just want R 1 and R 2 to
both be normalized subsets of rows of a
and yeah so here we're thinking of R 1
and R 2 as independence of dimension and
U is like a small matrix it's also
independent of dimension and so you
might be able to see how you could get
this by repeatedly approximating matrix
products and I'm going to so so and in
fact
this is basically all you need to give
analogues to quantum machine learning
algorithms and the reason for that is
that if you have an AR you already
composition and you have sampling quarry
access to your say like your input
vector so this is this is the analog to
a being in cue Ram and if you have
sampling quarry access to V which is
equivalent to V being your input quantum
states then you can have sampling query
access to R this R u R V which is
basically like the desired output
expression and your blow up is this
thing so R 1 R 2 as I mentioned was
independent of dimension it was like
when I reps on and log 1 over Delta here
and this is kind of like you can think
about it as its enforcing sort of like a
stable rank condition and also a
cancellation so you can think about like
if you have a if you're familiar
sometimes quantum machine learning
algorithms require projection and this
projection succeeds with certain
probability this encodes that
probability so so this is like kind of
what's happening there's also and it's a
stable rank in there but in any case
it's you don't need to worry about it
because this is just what this this
turns out to work for a quantum machine
learning analogues
uh which polynomial it's maybe squared
so the r1 r2 is linear one over epsilon
might be squared and this might be
squared the the the main contribution
will be from the r1 and r2 actually
because that will be something like 1
over epsilon squared yeah
okay and so I'm gonna assert that for
our applications it suffice it's fine
and are you ready composition I'll show
this a little bit more later okay and
now we can get to our main theorem which
is this even singular value
transformation I mentioned earlier
basically if we have sampling query
access to a and we have some sort of
smoothness conditions on F n f bar which
is f of X over X so this is our F that
we want to perform the singular value
transformation on so the slip shits
condition means that you know if F is
smooth then the derivative of F is
bounded by L and then correspondingly
for f bar and the idea is that we can
find an ru our decomposition for f of a
dagger a we're this is what I call us to
even singular value transformation
because you can this is like applying
even functions to your singular values
and our and you have basically this this
R in the dimension which is this
expression and then it takes R squared C
time where C is this so I'll explain
more about what this how to interpret
this stuff but first I want to show the
proof because it's really simple or a
proof sketch the idea is that we want to
apply f of a tiger a we want to
approximate sorry F of a dagger a and to
do that we have a dagger a and we have
sampling for e access to a so we
approximate the matrix product and so R
is like this si I mentioned earlier so
we approximate a dagger a and we get
these smaller matrices are dagger are so
these dots are representing dimensions
that are bad for me so these are like
the M's and the big M's and the begins
and so these are the dimensions that
don't want to see
and then what I can do is I can write
this F of our Duggar R as this
expression so recall that F bar of X was
equal to f of X over X so what this is
saying is that for example if like R is
a scalar this is saying that F of R
squared is equal to R squared times F
bar of our squared this kind of makes
sense
and you show this by looking at the
singular value decomposition in any case
so you just write this as it's this and
the reason that you do this is that now
you can approximate this this matrix
product here this RR dagger using that
you had sampling for e access to our
dagger because you had sampling coring
access to a and then so you can
approximate it again into something even
smaller and this is your R you are at
decomposition so R was a subset of rows
of a and this is a matrix that's
independent of dimension and so this is
our you usually the sticking point is
the nexus close to zero so then it could
be high but that's that's something you
have to pay anything right yeah yeah
this is basically why yeah you you the
yeah the Lipschitz constant will this is
why it works for low rank things but not
things that aren't lower rank I suppose
yeah this is the proof sketch if you
take these tilde tilde and or like a
approximations and then write the full
thing out you get the thing I said
before so this is section that I talking
about kind of to give some intuition
here behind these numbers if we only
wanted additive error which is basically
kind of like so if you think about
epsilon times spectrum one with a f of a
dagger a or I guess you could really
what you you are looking at is like sort
of the maximum F can be that's sort of
the additive error here then if you need
R to be independent of dimension recall
that this is exactly what we needed in
order to have our class or classical
algorithms be as fast as the quantum
algorithms then we need L to be not much
larger than this constant so basically
what's happening here is that if f is
like a linear function or something then
L is exactly equal to this expression
and so kind of what's going on is that L
needs to be not much like it needs to be
like non smooth not as much as you would
expect or or sorry there's a certain
amount that you would expect L to you
would expect L to be a particular size
based off of like how large F can be
this is what this max is and basically
it says that L can't be much larger and
this as our I met Robbie mentioned this
L prime really encodes so L prime is the
Lipschitz function of the lip-to-lip
shit's constant of f bar and this is
really encoding like a low rank
condition kind of and if it if a is
actually low rank if it has a minimum
singular value then you actually do get
that C's are with some condition number
factors on to it right
so I'm gonna skip this slide I think so
if you wanted to know how these these
like previous theorems affected the
applications so basically we can rewrite
all every all of our applications and
terms the singular value decomposition
or singular value transformations like
this recommendation Simms algorithm from
Karen a December cosh the idea is that
we want want to sample from the I throw
of a times this projection matrix and
what this projection matrix is is you
can write it as a singular value
transformation and then so you can
approximate it by are you are and then
as I mentioned before we can say it we
can get Sam we can get a sample from ru
R times a vector which is exactly what
this is
they're the support vector machines
application which is getting sampling
access to this expression here and if
you notice this is exactly a singular
value transformation you have to adjust
it to make sure it it thresholds that a
particular singular vector but then
everything goes through and you have ru
R tends a vector this desired to get a
low rank matrix inversion so like a
pseudo inverse B type of results what
you do is you write a pseudo inverse P
is like a like it was like the normal
equations I guess so you write it in
terms of in this way and then again a
dagger a pseudo inverse this is a
singular value transformation i
approximated by are you are and then i
have r u r times a matrix times a vector
but I have sampling for e access to a
and R
so I can approximate this are a dagger
and I get this is this is an R u R
decomposition so I get an R you already
composition this is the R this UW is the
new you because our had small heights
and
large wit so now it has small height and
small wit and so that's it basically
just follows through and notice that
this this technique works for any odd
function and so if we wanted to for
example do a Hamiltonian simulation we
rewrite as an odd function odd function
plus an even function and then
approximate them each one individually
and then do the same thing that we did
for the odd case over here so so
generally this is my slide on like
exponential speed-up thank you ml so
generally none of this effects this h HL
and basically sparsity base block
encodings and so they still give
exponential speed ups but it's not clear
how to apply them in practice because
input data isn't well conditioned enough
and basically this this this work is is
arguing that this qml and lowering data
basically showed potential for avoiding
these issues of conditioning but there's
a lot less hope for it now now that
these sort of wide framework papers this
is a wide wide swaths of be quantized
algorithms exist and q Malan quantum
data is so fun still seems like you can
get to beat up there okay
what is the destination of the
conditioning to the data you refer to
the matrix of the vector then makes the
data is not well conditioning up to do
fire labrie I guess like
what I mean is I mean the I mean the
matrix but I guess it's like fine if you
it's fine if your input data it's like
close to low rank like if you have a
bunch of vectors that are supposed to be
somehow kind of low rank and then like
you want to perform PCA and then like
dimensionality reduce another vector
then you you only need that back to it
to be like it's basically like jointly
you need the vector in the matrix to
have being sort of the same subspace
vector which is a prepared from some
easy to get vector and apply some load
that one circuit to it that's still fine
sorry fine means the elements dealer has
a bank all right sorry again so what I
mean is that from this right side of the
vector doesn't I don't know what do you
mean by the low-rank knees of that
particular right side vector
yes I'm talking about few things at the
same time so did you say what is the
requirement of the plan and then yeah
because you're in any other okay so
thanks very much